Traductor: José Miguel Godoy Muñoz
Revisor: María Julia Galles de Rois
Estamos en junio,
tras una fuerte lluvia,
y el cielo se llena de criaturas que
normalmente no esperaríamos encontrar ahí.
A primera vista esto puede
parecer un poco perturbador.
Pero para los afortunados machos
y hembras de Solenopsis invicta,
también conocidos como hormigas
rojas de fuego, es un día de romance.
Este es el vuelo nupcial,
donde miles de hormigas
macho y hembra fértiles,
llamadas voladoras o aladas,
vuelan por primera y última vez.
Pero incluso para los machos que logran
evitar a los depredadores alados,
este apareamiento frenético será letal.
Y para las hembras fertilizadas,
su trabajo tan solo dará comienzo.
Habiendo asegurado un suministro de
esperma de por vida de su difunta pareja,
nuestra nueva reina ahora debe comenzar
una nueva colonia por sí misma.
Descenderá bajo tierra
buscando el lugar adecuado
para construir su nido.
Lo idóneo será que encuentre
un suelo fácil de escavar,
como tierras de cultivo, ya alteradas
por la actividad humana.
Una vez que encuentra el sitio perfecto,
se arranca las alas,
y crea las dos protuberancias
que establecen su estatus real.
Después, comienza a excavar un túnel
descendente que termina en una cámara.
Aquí, la reina comienza a poner
sus huevos, unos diez al día;
las primeras larvas nacen a la semana.
En las tres semanas siguientes,
la nueva reina dependerá de un lote
diferente de huevos sin fertilizar
para alimentarse a sí misma
y a su descendencia,
y en el proceso perderá
la mitad de su peso corporal.
Afortunadamente, a los 20 días,
estas larvas crecerán y darán lugar
a la primera generación de trabajadoras,
listas para buscar comida
y mantener a su reducida reina.
Sus hijas tendrán que trabajar rápido;
devolverle la salud a su madre es urgente.
En el área circundante,
docenas de reinas vecinas construyen
sus propios ejércitos de hormigas.
Estas colonias han coexistido
pacíficamente hasta ahora,
pero una vez aparezcan las obreras,
comenzará el fenómeno conocido
como incursión por la progenie.
Las obreras de los nidos
situados a varios metros
comienzan a secuestrar
a la progenie de nuestra reina.
Nuestra colonia toma represalias,
pero nuevas olas de saqueadoras
procedentes de incluso mayor distancia
aplastan a las obreras.
En cuestión de horas, los atacantes
han llevado a todo el suministro de crías
al nido de mayor tamaño más cercano,
y las hijas de la reina que
han sobrevivido la abandonan.
Buscando su última
oportunidad de sobrevivir,
la reina sigue el rastro de
las saqueadoras hasta el nido ganador.
Ahuyenta a otras reinas perdedoras
y a las obreras defensoras del hormiguero,
y lucha hasta llegar a lo alto
de la pila de crías.
Las hijas ayudan a su madre a ganar
donde otras reinas fracasan,
vencen a la monarca actual
y usurpan la pila de la progenie.
Con el tiempo, el resto
de contrincantes fracasará
hasta que solo quede
una reina y una pila de crías.
Ahora, presidiendo a cientos
de obreras en el gran nido vecino,
nuestra reina victoriosa dirige
a su colonia hacia su objetivo principal:
la reproducción.
Durante varios años, la colonia
solo producirá obreras estériles.
Pero, una vez que la población
supere las 23 000 hormigas,
cambiará su curso.
A partir de ahora, cada primavera,
la colonia producirá machos
y hembras fértiles alados.
La colonia produce estas grandes
hormigas a principios del verano
y vuelve a producir obreras en otoño.
Tras fuertes lluvias,
las aladas vuelan hacia el cielo
y esparcen los genes de su reina
hasta unos 200 metros a favor del viento.
Para contribuir a este frenesí
de apareamientos anual,
la colonia debe seguir prosperando
como un único súper organismo masivo.
Cada día, las hormigas más jóvenes
alimentan a la reina
y atienden a la progenie,
mientras las obreras más mayores
buscan comida y defienden el nido.
Cuando los intrusos ataquen,
estas ancianas guerreras los
ahuyentarán utilizando venenos.
Después de cada lluvia,
la colonia se reúne,
y usa la tierra mojada
para expandir su nido.
Y si una inundación desastrosa
alcanza su hogar,
las hermanas se unen entre sí
para formar una gran balsa viva
que lleve a su reina a salvo.
Pero, por muy fuerte que sea,
la vida de una colonia debe terminar.
Tras unos 8 años, nuestra reina
se queda sin esperma
y no puede sustituir
a las obreras que mueren.
La población del hormiguero
disminuye y, con el tiempo,
es derrotada por una colonia vecina.
El reinado de nuestra reina ha acabado,
pero su legado genético sigue vivo.